[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the hall of fame coach football
night america analyst won a super bowl
as head coach of the colts
won a super bowl as a player with the
steelers you know what let me start
there tony dungy
give me the steeler defender who made
you nervous
he scared you the steeler defender who
made
me or other people nervous well both
[Laughter]
well uh two i'll have to start with two
ernie holmes was the one who made
everybody else nervous he was
a great player he was uh not a real
stable person
and when he turned it on he could
dominate a game now the guy who made me
nervous was jack lambert
uh the very first my rookie year lambert
was holding out
so we're in the fourth preseason game
he's coming back
first time i met him first time i'm in
the huddle in practice
and he looks at me and he gives me the
the call we break the huddle he said now
you know when we play on saturday i
won't have my teeth in so you may not be
able to understand it if you can't
understand me tap me on the shoulder and
i'll give you the hand signal
and i'm thinking what you won't have
your teeth in
but he was a mess that we we had some
characters on that defense
but you know the raiders are given
credit for having those personalities
did pittsburgh have it they just didn't
flaunt it the way the raiders did
that's exactly right coach noel was
great he he didn't uh
you know he didn't sterilize the group
but he he said
you've got to be yourself but on the
field off the field we've got to have a
little bit of
discipline and so we had some guys i
mean joe green
wasn't named me and joe green for
nothing jack was crazy
ernie holmes was was different dwight
white was very different
um mel blunt we had some tough guys and
uh they they had some different
personalities
frenchie fuqua uh maybe the most
flamboyant guy in the league
okay did he have shoes that had goldfish
in the
in the heel like he had glass bottom
shoes
the goldfish were gone by the time i got
there i read about that i never saw them
but i did see him come in
on a friday morning for practice
just in shorts and t-shirt and
flip-flops and he had a garment bag over
his shoulder
after practice he was going out on
friday night and it was a tuxedo
outfit matching cape mashing matching
cane
matching hat i mean it was just
unbelievable but that
that was a crew it was a group give me a
mean joe green story um
joe used to tell us he used to get very
mad at guys who got personal foul
penalties for retaliation
so you can't let a guy get to you like
that there's ways you can retaliate you
have to keep yourself under control
and retaliate while the play is going
somewhere down the line
you can't fight during you know when
when the clock is stopped and when the
officials are looking
and we're out in denver and uh denver
had an offensive guard named paul howard
who joe thought was holding him
he turned around to the umpire uh right
behind him
and gave the best line i've ever heard
he said if you don't stop this guy from
holding me you're going to go to jail
because i'm going to kill him and you're
going to go as accessory to a murder
and then he proceeded two plays later he
hit paul howard in the stomach with a
body punch that knocked him out
during the play and uh i think he got
fined afterwards but never penalized for
it
but when he did the mean joe green
coca-cola commercial
what that changed everything it felt
like
lambert was so mad at him after that he
said you're done you're through
we have no more the real joe green we've
got this fake joe green now
and i don't know if we can win another
super bowl
i mean i we didn't even talk about the
offense here tony because he had terry
bradshaw he joins us next hour but
i mean terry was a little wacky he was
not as wacky as he is now
or was it was he wacky then no he was
he would he would uh do the interviews
after the game
and back then there were different
stations and they would come to you one
at a time
and he'd laugh he'd say i'm gonna tell
them something different every single
one so they
tell me about this touchdown pastor
swann and he tell channel seven
well i came up with that play and i did
this until a whole long two-minute story
and then channel nine would come and
he'd say
yeah star wars suggested that play and i
was i would think to myself don't you
realize
all of these are going to eventually be
shown and it's going to
you know seem like you don't know what
you're doing but he was so funny uh one
of my best
terry bradshaw memories you have to ask
him about it back in the day
we used to have a pay phone only at the
end of the hallway in the door
you know there was no cell phones or
that so you had to wait in line for
for the pay phone bradshaw was on the
phone one night
with a whole line of people waiting on
the phone he's on there for two hours
buying a horse
on the on the phone that he had never
seen before somebody's describing it to
him and how much should i pay for this
horse
and is it fast and is he going to win
the kentucky derby
and we're all sitting hey i got to talk
to my girlfriend i got to talk to my
wife and he's buying a horse
we're talking on the phone talking to
tony dungy the hall of famer football
night in america
analyst i'm gonna make you the defensive
coordinator for the buccaneers
you're todd bowles what do you want the
chiefs to do
i want them to have to throw 10 passes
on a drive to score
i don't want to see the 75-yard bomb to
tyreke hill i don't want to see the
40-yard pass to travis kelsey now i
think i've got a little edge in this
game that i didn't have in the last game
because
last time we played them now they don't
have their left tackle
and that dp that's a critical critical
injury because
what kansas city has to do that really
hurts them at three positions
now the right tackle has moved over the
left tackle he's not as good as fisher
okay the right guard had to move the
right tackle he's not as good as the
right
tackle and then the backup right guard
is in so they're weaker at three
positions in the offensive line
so i'm telling all my guys jason
pierre-paul
shaq barrett and dominic and sue
goldston
you guys have to win the game we can't
blitz and leave our guys one-on-one
you guys have to beat this banged up
offensive line and put
some pressure on my homes that's how
we're going to win the game all right
you're steve spagnolo
now what are you going to do is the
defensive coordinator with the chiefs
what do you want
the buccaneers to do got to pressure tom
brady
up inside and we've got to cover tight
not let him throw the ball quick and get
rid of it rodney harrison has been
beside me for 12 years telling me that's
how you
have to play time you got to pressure
him you got to bang the receiver so he
can't throw it quick
so that uh means chris jones you got to
have a big game
pass rushing inside we may send some
blitzes inside
defenders a lot of bump and run coverage
uh
we might be even okay if they throw one
deep ball but we're not gonna let tom
just get in that rhythm of
eight or ten balls in a row just short
quick get it out of his hand we've got a
pressure
i was also wondering about this that you
know we talk about
quarterbacks and sometimes we'll say boy
aaron rodgers the most talented
quarterback
but here's brady who is not the most
talented it's not like he's slowing down
because he was never
fast enough to slow down
he still does what he's been doing for a
long time but
can you teach pocket presence
not really you either have it or you
don't he has it mahomes has great pocket
presence and can move around and feel
people around him tom does the same
thing he can
see people around and feel people around
him and still keep his eyes down the
field
he knows when he's got to get rid of the
ball uh he he's great
and he if you have him on rhythm he's as
good as anybody who's ever played
and now he's got probably a better
receiving core than he's had since that
2007 group with randy moss and welker i
mean he's got some talented guys so
uh what he's done this year without the
benefit of the timing and
all the off season program and
everything it's pretty amazing
andy reid if he wins another super bowl
that changed things in how he's viewed
it it pretty much he might be a hall of
famer now i'm guessing tone
yeah he's a hall of famer if he wins
this super bowl i think he's a lock
how many people have won back to back
super bowls not that many
how many people have taken two different
franchises to the super bowl
uh not that many coaches how many people
have done it for this long a period of
time
and this offense that that he's put
together over the last
if he goes five more years with patrick
mahomes they'll put up numbers that
we we have never seen before so yeah i
think he's a lock for the hall of fame
but this would
solidify it and you knew this you were a
college quarterback um
and it's something we've talked about
before but you know when we profiled
black quarterbacks coming out of college
to go into the nfl
warren moon threw as good a deep ball as
anybody who's ever played the game in my
opinion
and he wasn't this scrambling
quarterback but he had to go to the
canadian football league
and i don't know if lamar jackson
has helped in the profile or patrick
mahomes
has helped in profiling and maybe
profiling is the wrong word here
but it feels like maybe reverse
profiling here
who do you think has helped that
position with african-americans
more as we move forward what lamar has
done or mahomes
no i think the guy who really has done
the most for it
is russell wilson russell wilson comes
in
six foot tall not the big powerful
you know prototypical quarterback he
moves around
he scrambles he makes what we call off
scheduled plays
and he did that and took a team to the
super bowl and so yeah doug williams
took a team to a super bowl but he's 6'4
220 rocket arm pocket passer that's what
we're looking for
but now here's russell going with a
completely different direction
and taking a team to a super bowl and i
think that's what let
some scouts and maybe even some coaches
say you know what if i design some
things and do what these guys can do i
can present some problems
and now you see russell wilson
followed by desean watson and
lamar jackson tyler murray and peter
kyler murray and
defenses saying wow now i've got to
design some specific things
i can't play all the coverages that i
normally play because
lamar jackson can take off and run 75
yards if i'm in man coverage and
nobody's spying him
and giving defenses different problems
so
i think it's been great to see how these
guys are being utilized
and so that is not only african-american
quarterbacks but
baker mayfield and josh allen's now
we're seeing these this type of day
and it's always interesting when you
talk to you know defensive players
if you know the frustrating part is
brady's right there
like he's like and but like but you know
frank clark says you know he might just
dip his shoulder a little bit
but that's even more frustrating it
feels like he's right there
and i might not be able to do anything
about it whereas
you know russell or kyler or these guys
who can get out of mahomes
josh allen i don't know what would be
more frustrating i would think that
you know the mobile guy puts more
pressure on you but as a defender
that guy's you know three feet away from
me and i can't get to him
tom is probably more frustrating for
those defensive linemen because of just
what you're saying i'm close i'm
thinking i'm getting pressure and here
the ball comes out and it's the 18-yard
completion
but i'll tell you for the coach the the
john elway
russell wilson lamar jack you do
everything right you defend the play
and you've got kind of got him squeezed
in the pocket everybody's covered
should be a win for the defense and now
he moves around
and mahomes throws 55 yards across field
to
to demarcus robinson and you say
what am i going to do and and that
that's the frustration john elway used
to drive me nuts
i was coaching secondary for the chiefs
and we got
plaster guys back there kevin ross and
albert lewis and we're on guys for
eight nine seconds and then all of a
sudden he
scrambles out and throws one across the
field 55 yards to the tight end
and it's it's crazy and you say what are
we going to do
it's just he was impossible to to defend
um do you have a team you're picking
here
do you have to pick tampa because you
live in tampa no i tell you what i'm
really
concerned and worried i don't know who's
going to play still
uh i don't know who's going to get a
haircut and not be able to play in the
game
and you know that that is crazy that
that
we still don't know exactly who's going
to be out there i'm worried about the
kansas city
offensive line i think if all things
were equal
everybody's healthy i would pick the
chiefs but i think this line could
get overmatched and it could present
some problems yeah i'm there with you
i i think that this game will be won by
you know your offensive line in your
defensive line and and who's able to
protect and who can put pressure there
did did brady's success put more
pressure
on peyton manning to be successful
because a lot of times you guys would
match up in the playoffs like i didn't
know
if peyton compared himself to tom or
everything he did was measured against
tom
and here's tom going to more super bowls
and uh
what that did no i don't think it was
that but we did know we're gonna have to
beat the patriots that that was
said so you you start focusing in on
them what are we gonna have to do
to win win these matchups and
yeah we all wanted to go to super bowls
and i know
peyton wanted to go to more than tom did
you know but uh to do that we're gonna
have to beat the patriots so that was
always our focus coming into the season
do you know
brady better than belichick
or either one uh i don't know either one
really well tom
though really fascinating i um you know
sent him a text when he came here i said
it's gonna be hard to root for you but
your home team now
and so i'm gonna have to he's sending
the text back
and then uh i think shannon sharp talked
about the
how i ranked the quarterbacks five years
ago or something so that brought up a
little
animosity i guess but then i sent tom a
text of my son
jordan who wanted a brady hoodie for
christmas
and i got it for him and i sent the
picture to tom and he laughed
and he sent jordan an autographed jersey
and you know
you know just notes to my boys so it's
been really good it's been
nice seeing him do well and have fun
here in tampa wait
give me how did you rank these
quarterbacks that it bothered tom
um i had him at number six
and i just no i i started out with the
premise dan
that first of all you can't rank them by
who's the best
it's impossible to rank my dad would say
otto graham's the best
ever and i couldn't argue with that how
do i know
between eras yeah so i started out the
piece with i'm not gonna go by who's the
best
i'm gonna tell you who was the most
problematic for me personally
preparing okay john and i started with
john elway because of just the story
that i told you
and then aaron rodgers and steve young
the mobile guys who you could defend
everything
and then steve steve young ran 75 yards
through the whole minnesota vikings team
broke about 20 tackles
you know so i'm gonna put those guys
first now
i'm going to go to my pocket passers and
well of course everybody then how can
you have tom brady six he
won 55 super bowls and i said that
wasn't the point of it it wasn't who won
the most super bowls who was the best
who was the toughest to really handle
the best pocket
passer in your opinion of all time is
who
again is still hard to say uh modern era
modern era
just they were known as a pocket passer
it is payton better than tom as a pocket
passer
you know i'm always going to go with
peyton because he was my quarterback but
i'll say this
there's some guys one moon you talk
about stand in the pocket and give
somebody
protection and watch the ball just be
intimidated by how pretty the ball comes
out and how on target it is
uh jake we had a receiver in minnesota
jake reed who they said didn't really
have great hands
jake caught a hundred passes one year
because every ball was between
eight and six he didn't have to use his
hands at all
and and so you know there's some guys
who could throw some pretty balls
randall cunningham
it was a pretty pocket passer ball jeff
george
um so there's some guys that you
wouldn't put in the top of the
quarterback list but if you
said hey i can protect them and just
watch them throw from the pocket
you'd put jeff george with anybody he
did throw a great deep ball
but problem is that maybe the guy on the
receiving end wasn't always
are you watching at home are you going
to be at the stadium
i may end up going to the game i wanted
to watch at home my boys want to go to
the game
so we're kind of fighting uh that that
battle right now but
probably going to end up at the game
great to see you
tell the boys i said hello and i will
thank you tom
we got to get up and see you sometime
hey you got to get up
when you when you uh you guys are doing
football night in america if you uh
you know you want to come to the man
cave you know post covert we got to get
there that would
be great thank you bud all right
tony dungey hall of famer